Reporting live, I'm Kate Bradley,
Channel 12 News.
You were meant for the bummer beat.
Fires, car crashes,
Black Friday riots at the mall.
Look out!
The station management are going nuts
with all the risks you're taking.
-I call that being a reporter.
-It's got to stop.
There was a call from a woman
in the South Bronx
saying she found a bag full of cash.
She's convinced it was given to her
by a good Samaritan.
Consider this a break
from the bummer beat.
A woman finds a bag of money.
I mean, where's the story?
You don't buy the good Samaritan angle?
I remain objective always. But, no.
There is someone out there,
looking over and helping us.
It's hard to believe that there's
somebody out there doing good deeds
and expecting nothing in return.
It's real. I found it in front
of our front door this morning.
He left the bag here.
Just last week, eight people
found 100 grand on their doorsteps.
We're looking for the good Samaritan
who's behind it.
A woman started an anonymous
good Samaritan club.
And some guy in line at the grocery store
anonymously paid for the next ten people.
When I first got put on this story,
I was sure Good Sam
had some ulterior motive.
But there are way more people out there
doing good.
Interest in Good Sam continues to grow
with these random acts of generosity
and when and where the next bag of money
might appear.
People say New York City is a tough place.
But thanks to Good Sam,
I see more kindness between strangers.
Good Sam is an inspiring hope.
In times like these, people need it.
It's spreading, like miracles do.
The question at the top
of every New Yorker's mind,
"Good Sam, who are you?"